Facebook executive Sheryl Sandberg is
out with a new book this morning about
coping with grief option B already tops
the bestseller list on Amazon in her
first in-depth interview since her
husband's death she explains how she
pulls meaning out of her tragedy to help
people get through hard times here's
more of our conversation from CBS Sunday
morning including parts you did not see
yesterday I mean it seemed like a normal
day we got up in the morning we had
breakfast with the group we went on a
hike Sheryl Sandberg and her husband
Dave Goldberg were vacationing in Mexico
with friends two years ago so tell you
about that moment when you realize
something was wrong well I've been
asking where he was you know anyone seen
Dave does anyone seen Dave and someone's
like oh he was going to the gym maybe
he's back in the room maybe he's out
having drinks with friends but when he
didn't show up for dinner I was like
dave is not here and my sister-in-law
yelled out like where's the gym how did
you find Dave when you entered the gym
um he was lying on the floor his head
was turned there's a little bit of blood
under his head and I just screamed what
were your initial thoughts I mean what
did you think had happened I thought he
had fallen off an exercise machine and
that was what the initial report said
but then we got an autopsy and the
autopsy showed that he died of coronary
artery disease he had a cardiac
arrhythmia so he died before he hit the
floor that's why he fell that's why he
fell and I thought he died from falling
off an exercise machine I thought what
if I had looked for him sooner what if I
you know had assuming he went to the gym
and found him could I have saved him
right and it wasn't true I couldn't have
but one of the things I learned writing
this book is that we blame ourselves we
blame ourselves when it's our fault we
blame ourselves when it's not our fault
and not blaming ourselves is such a huge
part of recovery the book published
today is option B facing adversity
building resilience and finding joy
written with psychologist Adam grant and
how do you develop resilience we develop
resilience by believing
that we will get through hard things we
grow stronger by living through horrible
moments or real adversity I never
thought I would live through some of
those unimaginable moments but I have
grown stronger my kids have perspective
I would never wish on them but it is
perspective
my son's basketball team lost the
playoffs a few weeks ago and all the
other kids were really upset and I said
are you okay and he looked at me and
said mom this is sixth-grade basketball
I'm fine well I'm fine yeah the book
option B is on sale today and you can
hear more from my conversation with
Sandberg on our CBS this morning podcast
find it on iTunes and Apple's podcast
app I went to a book party yesterday for
Sheryl Sandberg and nor you should know
everybody including Sheryl was
complimenting you about that interview
they thought you captured it brilliantly
I did too but she says it's a book that
she never planned or wanted to write
yeah and that now that it's here she
hopes it and I believe that it will help
a lot of people's self expression self
compassion and that it's okay to find
joy again Hart is it for her to revisit
so true Charlie you know we interview a
lot of people on this show you know this
is really one of the hardest interviews
I've ever done because it will talk to
someone about something so personal is
really I didn't realize she had found
him Nora I do I like that that's very
tough that's the one really do a really
good book you're right about that